welcome to this video playing spyro on
us spyro be maybe um maybe a French
let's try okay it can also play Sicilian
why not hmm c3 okay yeah maybe g5 to go
for French structure or should I take
what I could also take with the Queen
once let's see I already don't show that
line but it should be okay right hmm
really you want to trade your bishop
that ID nah he wants yeah this is really
shouldn't job shouldn't be any any
danger there shouldn't be a much danger
here mmm taking on should be seven where
we just just develop h3 I know I see the
point you wanted to make sure that I
don't play Knight g-form okay
now let's attack be too maybe Bishop c5
as a move yeah what is playing this some
very unambitious Lee but not sure that I
can really benefit from that very much
I'm certainly ok but not not much better
or anything ask c4 I didn't really
didn't really look at this move very
much but it is a very logical of course
ok I text my queen and protects be too
we should see five min are probably
I wonder if Knight b6 is a move or look
at the eight maybe start with r up the
aid that looks a bit annoying for him
via exactly with with the opposition
here of Queen anthem and rook Knight b6
maybe or the trade and Knight b6 I I can
take this may be so some way to use this
slightly this is not a very good
coordination and white maybe this
attending rook t3r queen bee form I can
still play b3 up if I go queen before I
can still play be three
yeah this wasn't any good yeah okay I
read I don't have any any big problem
here but I was thinking that I could
maybe try to do something but it does
not look like that at all check nice
busy chopping off material here um how
do i play now I mean I have I have from
the default that's not bad and it is not
that easily opposing we need to look the
one I still have a to attack so maybe I
can oks careful before
maybe queen bee six after the Queen
trade route d3 is very good the double
point isn't isn't a problem at all
nowaday also have 94 that's quite ok now
the only question is how big big of an
edge it really is it's ok really can
play 94 kini to I have look at three
that's quite nice
yeah and that's pressure now 95 is
possible and of course just night takes
a three years very simple threat
what about rook takes a three is in this
instance it's just just winning or is my
night trapped at the end this is
possible GF Knight c3 check Kingda three
night eggs b1a4 but it takes ages ready
to catch it cannot really believe in
that cat is doing playing the other
recapture after that I'm getting here
rather easily i know i have b5 coming b5
I can just just approach here time boys
what's easier now be five probably it's
better to play play this first
yep King and porn end game with an extra
porn good to have
yeah now is sinking into deep thought
after playing very committal moves
almost immediately let's just see that I
get the person
check white resins cannabis was a really
weird that he took took ages and then
still played kini too okay so what
should why do the comp suggestion is to
play rookie one interesting this makes
make some sense ideas to answer f5 with
rupee for yeah that looks ok this is
this is losing you to the root gap three
idea mmm is there something else I don't
know I'm threatening ruka three so he
probably really needs to react to it
they are Mookie one is there some other
move this is I think my can also maybe
take I can see I can do that it just
which is quite strong okay so looky 192
is nonsense I was thinking that this
also might be an idea but he's got it is
getting in this and probably 95 okay
okay okay okay but rookie one mukhi one
definitely it's the best drive after
that I thought that this is maybe a bit
tougher check but like this try to to
trap my night but I can also just just
lettin know that if you
and just push em yeah and I'm just quick
enough maybe this is this is more
precise yeah black should win Wow yeah
okay so i'll say that it's it's much
easier in fact as I just get down and
yeah b5 was also possible but the king
and on end game is a very simple win
okay thanks for watching